the argument that I make in the book is
that a lot of women are trying pretty
hard to have sex like men and are being
quite strongly encouraged by the culture
and by the men in their lives to attempt
the high sociosexuality kind of way of
being one of the things I examine at one
point is articles in women's bags about
how not to catch feelings and they're
always framed very carefully in a
gender-neutral way so that a person
didn't want to catch feelings from their
relationship with another person how
would they do that but it's very obvious
that actually what we're talking about
here is women getting emotionally
attached in these sexual relationships
and not wanting to I think this is like
holding me back I want it to be behaving
as if I had unrestricted socio sexuality
I want to be like participating in
hookup culture like a man but I have
these like niggling feelings which keep
getting in the way unless you want to
say I suppose it's socialization the
childhood socialization goes that deep
that it can't be undone maybe but I
think Occam's razor says it's just the
difference there's a difference that's
by far the simplest explanation for what
we see across the world
oh